rencontre importante aujourd'hui à
moscou vladimir poutine reçoit le
premier ministre arménien nikol
pashinian les deux hommes doivent
discuter de l'agenda politique arménien
alors que le pays traverse une profonde
crise politique suite à la guerre de
l'automne dernier dans le haut-karabagh
à nikol pashinian très fragilisées a
annoncé sa démission pour le mois
d'avril ainsi que des élections
législatives anticipées prévues pour le
20 juin prochain
elle voyait justement à les explications
avec antoine clients le premier ministre
arménien se rend à moscou afin de
discuter principalement de questions de
défense
en effet nicolas pas chine yann compte
rééquiper l'armée arménienne qui a
souffert de la comparaison avec l'armée
azerbaïdjanaise
lors du récent conflit entre les deux
pays à propos du haut karabagh il sera
bien évidemment aussi question de suivre
les progrès accomplis dans cette région
depuis le cessez le feu conclu en
novembre dernier en particulier dans le
domaine des liens économiques et des
liaisons de transport dans toute la zone
du caucase du sud l'arménie depuis
l'accord de paix du 9 novembre a perdu
les trois quarts des territoires qu'elle
contrôlait dans le haut-karabagh ce qui
a provoqué une grave crise politique et
l'annoncent d'élections législatives
anticipées pour le mois de juin